hey how well did you know chris dolman
uh fairly well i mean when we were
growing up i figured he was probably at
the house once or twice a week wow
yeah i mean pops and him played together
for 11 years i'm only thinking like what
what me and mark ingram were right
like eight years together saw my guy
every day at the locker room you know my
kids know his kids my girl knows his
girl my parents know his parents you
know everybody's at this part of
football you're close yeah that's what
you know dole was to pops
about i've got memories you've got you
know nothing but pictures of
us as kids playing around everybody's at
birthday parties whatever it is it's
like you know
as you grow up you play defensive end
and you automatically you emulate some
of the greats you immunity
and then you're able to talk to him
you're able to talk about it uh and it's
like hey like hey nephew like whenever
you get a chance like let me let me
imbue some knowledge on you right uh
when you go about your way it's like you
to realize you know
you have living legends like you know i
got to i got to grow up around chris
dolman i got to grow up around john
randall you know there's i know there's
hall of fame defensive lineman just
aplenty yeah in my life right and for me
to come out of defensive linemen it's
like yo i had all this access to him i
never even thought about using them
right like i never thought about going
to them because they're like yo that's
like that's not our wavelength that way
the line used to scare me when i played
my dad i used to be like oh dad's going
to get this [ __ ] keith in the middle
right
they were good and does it ever seem
weird to you cam that you're kind of at
a point now given everything you've
accomplished and what you've done you've
become kind of one of those guys like
just well that's the passage of time
that's
what's impossible no no that's you're
you're not you're selling yourself short
yeah you're just no man went 150 sacks
deep okay john randall would like a buck
30 something
okay i get you there you got time left
right how many do you have i've got 87.
all right so you're gonna get to 100
you're gonna get there for sure i feel
good when i like compare numbers to like
willie willie mcginnis and i'm like
he had 86. yeah great i passed him well
i i would say and again i like
i would say to this where it's not as
sexy like and maybe the hall of fame is
not going to recognize it you play the
run better than chris dolman did oh
absolutely like that's where people like
that's where it frustrates me i wonder
how what's your take on that when people
don't really understand that i've always
told you
i've always told my boys
so i got rookies coming in i got d-tac
was coming in and they're like hey man
like you know you you have all these
tfls like
i told sheldon ray because when he got
it he's like man he's like i'm gonna
leave the league in ten fails he's like
you know they're going they're gonna
respect me then i was like hey bro
you're gonna get respect from all the
players in the world but fans
fans are here for sex yeah i know if
it's not sex they honestly don't care
yeah so when you talk about probe
athletes that might never be you but in
terms of the football world right you
can submit yourself as one of the greats
definitely well there's a new stat that
we're trying to get the elias sports
bureau to officially recognize chris
came up with it it's basically called
the f up the play stat where
the
show goes out yeah no tackle no you say
it and i already already know what
you're talking about that's you you're
ruining the play
tackle absolutely right you me that says
i mean aaron donald's the king of that
absolutely right okay and you do it a
lot too davey and clowning probably is
like one second they'll say no doubt
right you talk about messing up play
every play but he's like one step away
from second to quarterback one second
was one one step away from creating the
tfl right makes it you know running back
cut back right he's like the defense
just feeds into it absolutely there's
disrupters for sure yeah um and i
consider myself one of the better ones
at it as well you talk about disrupting
a play i may not make the tackle i may
not make the sack i may not you know
slot the ball down but maybe the
trajectory of the ball arcs right in
terms of like a screen or whatever
you're gonna have a swing play you know
the
the burning back has to bubble out
because you've set the edge of where you
have so now he's all the way at the end
line and the safety just comes up and
you know yeah or the quarter somebody's
open downfield but now you're in the
quarterback's face and he had to shuffle
and move and now he's not open because
you were there to disrupt it that way no
doubt i mean there's a man that way yeah
as a defensive lineman you look at that
you're like yeah like how can i affect
the play right i could care less about
outside perspective because in my eyes
i'm like yo i'm i've got to be the best
i've got to try to be the best i've got
to try and affect every play because i
feel like that's going to help my team
be better than what we were who's your
like who's your arch-nemesis in football
right now like tackle who's the one guy
and i know like you got great
self-confidence and you're the you're
the freaking man
but who is that guy where you always go
man okay this is gonna be tough day's
work right here
uh almost everybody i mean i look across
the league i'm like yo like even if even
if the tackle isn't up to par
um even if you know
i look at the titan i'm like if he's
ever crossed me i'm putting hands on
this man
i know i'm catching more than just the
tackle or the tight end right um you
know even if they leave the titan open
it's it's normally because we're in an
under front and i'm like low-key in a
five or i'm adjusted into a six sure so
i've got you know if i've got outside
container i've got to do all this extra
work so it looks like they're blocking
me and you look like you know you look
at some filming he's like like cam you
gotta do more
right
right you know you got random fans and
they're like oh why weren't you there on
the edge i was like well because we had
safety help so i technically wasn't
realizing it wasn't supposed to be a
responsibility he's like titan walled
you off right because i was never in
position to
be on a nine i was a five yeah not gonna
lie to you
right that's sort of systematically the
problem i know well yeah we got a lot of
armchair quarterbacks right we've heard
some stories this week about how your
meeting room got all stunk up by dead
fish after the win over seattle i forgot
about that he was out there chucking him
did he throw on your way no
thank the lord no what's like what's
what's the best one of the year or
what's your best one of sean that one
where mike nolan caught it and tried to
take a plug out the daggone sam salmon
yeah what he was he was ready he might i
might normally caught this big old
salmon
you know and then just like savagely
ripped a piece off of it i was like he
went through scales and all and i was
like that's impressive i was like yo i
can do that too i tried to like i tried
to like playfully bite in i was like no
i hope that fish didn't go to waste
though somebody cooked it and ate some
of that stuff most likely all right
14 of them okay
they weren't like they weren't just like
cuts of salmon from whole foods okay no
no this was like the real fish
absolutely right right he's not going
back to whole food after the butcher
gave him a hard time about that uh going
for two against the 49ers and he had to
tell the butcher worry about your own
meat oh that's the best the best the
best i was after that 49ers game give us
your scouting report on the 49ers
uh you know
we would watch film up until we played
them and it was like hey they're running
the ball the running ball the running
ball outside runs outside runs outside
runs we get into the game and i didn't
see outside run until the end of the
second quarter right um you know they
switched up the dna because as much as
we game plan they're game planning
themselves too so um you know the league
then had to adapt to them and you saw
guys adjust realizing they could do more
than just run the ball yeah um
do you feel like you guys are like
freaking cursed right now
i feel like we're always poised to be in
a position to make phenomenal runs right
um i feel that uh in terms of our
endings in the playoff runs i i feel
like
we can never really be caught in the
game we're not one of those teams that
that wins by a point or two in in the
playoffs we win by multiple touchdowns
yeah right um and you talk about
postseason from the last two years we
win like multiple touchdowns so anytime
we're sending a once one score matter
we're leaving it out of our hands we're
adding in the 12th man and that 12th man
doesn't necessarily like us and i'm not
talking about the 12th man in seattle no
i know don't talk about you know black
and white stripes
i think they broke out of broke out of
of saints prison or something to come
back for us uh because at this point i
feel like there's sort of a vindictive
effort here well yeah i mean we're with
you i mean you guys have been on you got
the the short straw a bunch and chris
asked alvin about this
idea that you guys were so close to
having a buy with the end of the
seahawks 49ers game jacob hollister
almost scores the touchdown how hard was
it to set aside the crap we should be
off this week well we got to focus on
playing a game like did that creep in at
all this idea that we shouldn't even be
playing this game you're gonna have to
worry about shouldn't be playing because
you are playing i mean if anything you
just cast that aside and and you focus
on exactly what you have to do um if
anything that cemented who we were
playing that week you know you had the
vikings you knew exactly what they had
to do um and everything that uh we
wanted to do as a team we had to
capitalize on the win
you talking to mccourty twins no doubt i
can't tell my partner interview here
okay can you can you please leave us
alone all right you two jersey misfits
could not tell them apart
it is hard i i've known them as they
were little and i still can't tell them
oh yeah without twins
[Laughter]
um you know but we talk about
everything that we are as athletes
everything that we train for um to not
only be ready for the season but just in
the off season keep our bodies right
keep our minds active like again i was
telling you that earlier i was i took a
run off on the beach this morning and
after the run is you know you got to
replenish your body what better way to
do it with superior hydration yeah body
armor um you know they have they have
the body armor here they have the body
armor lights uh which even cuts down
even more um but we talk about what it
brings back into to give you your
electrolytes it's coconut water based
right um it has it doesn't have the
additives that other you know sports
drinks have yeah which everybody has you
know no artificial sweeteners no added
dyes i'm big on that good um and in
today's society that's you know that's
huge
everybody's reading
everybody's you know looking for the
organic route and this is just a simple
way to to not only refresh your body and
give it what it needs but not have to
feel like i just you know had five
tables yeah sugar yeah right what do you
what do you like how conscious are you
like thursday friday saturday of
hydrating and like everything like going
into the game well i've got like you
know i've got the big leader bottles of
water
they've got the body armor water right i
mean you know so it's got the good ph in
it and i when i talk about ph like then
it's a whole another category i've got
guys that like are firm believers like
bro if it's not nine something ph like
i'm not drinking i'm like well i got
this body armor that you know what i'm
saying i've been drinking now for uh
like two years or so a year and a half
so it's like yo i can tell the
difference i now understand why you know
people just don't drink the generic
yeah they're brands that's right yeah
the other brands i hear yeah i hear you
yeah yeah i'm looking at this card yeah
nine-year veteran five-time pro bowler
selection does that you look at that and
you think that's not me that's somebody
else like nine nine did you ever think
only one first team all pro selection
because now we're like in this this
combination of edge and edge is like all
the skinny people in the world and then
there's defensive ends and i'm just
sitting there like
yeah we're edge yeah like i'm sitting
here as like the the grande maximo
burrito here and then they bring in like
a quesadilla and like hey you guys are
saying yeah yeah right yeah yeah no no
you're right i don't think you're you're
playing a different position right like
von miller or something like that that
would be beautiful yeah tj what like
stay on the outside
right yeah no way you're right and you
don't let us vote if we voted you'd be
all pro everything yeah i appreciate it
and all pro on the field and all pro
hair and chin the mustache the mustache
the mustache is probably like primo here
like it flips up what it wants to but i
keep it i'll keep it down i normally
just turn up for game days you you look
good man i appreciate it man there is
cam jordan ah good seeing you buddy
thanks for including us thank you for
having me thanks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports